I want to jump to the story from the
post millennial and we'll get into the
hard politics of this we have this story
Katie Hobbs press secretary resigns in
disgrace after posting threat of
violence against quote transphobes on
Twitter and the important bit here is
that the post was made Monday night well
after everyone already knew the
motivation of the of the show well I
presumed motivation of the shooter the
identity of the shooter and that there
was a Manifesto police had stated that
they believe the identity played a role
in the motivation and then she posted a
photo it says us when we see transphobes
and it's a picture of a woman holding
two handguns and clearly pointing them
at someone many people saw this as a
direct call for violence and the crazy
thing is Tucker Carlson did a segment
about this last week where he said these
people want to get guns he was talking
about trans activists taking up guns in
the threat of violence and then sure
enough only that he was roasted for that
left attacked him for it then come
Monday we get this this woman posted
this photo and left it up for days
she she did not take this down it was it
was taken down by Twitter I do not
believe she would have taken it down or
resigned unless she absolutely had to
because his borders on criminal activity
borders on I don't think she created
information that is a clear and present
threat but based on the call to the
trans day of Vengeance and we have it on
Monday she's basically there already
I think these people you saw what
happened with the Covington kids you
brought up Nick Sandman yeah they called
for the death of children
all because of video emerged showing a
Native American banging a drum in his
face that's all it was when I saw that
video everyone's like wow Tim you got to
see this video say something about it
and I was like what is there to say I
don't know what happened it's a kid with
a guy banging a drum in his face and
they're like yeah but look at that kid
look what he's doing I'm like what is he
doing he's standing there sure enough I
found the live stream that showed the
Native American man walked up to the kid
and banged the drum in his face and I'm
like why are y'all mad at the kid
they one guy posted a picture of a wood
chipper with blood coming out of it one
one guy I think it was Reza Aslan said
the kid was punchable these people are a
zombie mob they would not apologize to
take this down unless they were forced
to do so and when all that went down
many of them didn't they were calling
for the death of children with not they
didn't care about the facts they didn't
care about what was true and the media
lied to defend the mob this is why I'm
really worried especially about this
weekend because I can't see this going
in a positive direction not not in the
in the short term
I I mean
we're getting to a Tipping Point and
that's what I think worries me is that
what what is acceptable right that that
do they you know what what sort of act
of violence uh because this would have
normally gotten complete outrage uh the
idea that this is happening you talking
about it is probably the extent that
we're going to see of it it doesn't make
ABC News it doesn't make the Washington
poster the New York Times well I can't
guarantee if this was if this if you
take out Katie Hobbs and you write Glenn
Younkin or Ron DeSantis Lester Holt's
leading with this tonight let's go back
to the sports uh metaphor or analogy if
you went to a bar surrounded by everyone
wearing the same Jersey and said
something disparaging about the Jets
everyone's gonna laugh
No One's Gonna Go hey look man look it
goes a little too far there may be a
different team but we're all just trying
to be friends they'd be like yeah and
they'd high five you right they don't
care when you insult the opposing team
the only problem is a friendly sports
game it's fun to have that kind of
rivalry and and and it's it's almost
sometimes it gets out of hand you know
especially with soccer hooligans and
stuff but the the the Hokey like my team
is better than yours is is all in good
fun and we want our teams to win the
problem with this is they're telling
everyone it's life or death they're
saying the right wants to commit a
genocide well that level of rhetoric is
the is it's in the real world and these
are people who have guns and are doing
firearms training now what we saw on
Monday
they've been planning for things like
this these far left extremists but the
thing that I find funny too is it's the
opposite right I don't really care I
mean to be honest with you like my my
view has always been and I think
generally speaking people on the right
are like hey go live your life I don't
really care right I mean that's
generally people on the right generally
are like laissez-faire about what you
want to do with your life it's the
people on the left that are the most
intolerant they they preach tolerance
but they're the ones who actually want
to come out and attack people on the
right they they love to preach about
this idea of Tolerance but their idea of
tolerances agree with me about being
tolerant it's hard for me not to wonder
if this sort of you're right it won't
get picked up everywhere but a fair
number of people have talked about this
this tweet and how it seems just
obviously inappropriate uncalled for uh
completely insensitive it makes me
wonder uh Independence how they'll react
to it people who sort of not very
political they might lean a little bit
left they might lean a little bit right
but watching the the ground beneath them
shift and totally split they're gonna
have to make a decision on which side
they fall and I can't say that this is
enticing anyone to think highly of of
Katie Hobbs obviously it's not her
official account it wasn't from her it's
just someone who was in her
Administration I think these moments
where you have uh people siding with
someone who literally murdered children
and three adults you know it it comes
down to the independent voters what are
they going to do they're probably going
to side many of them like cowards with
whoever's in power but I think but but
my point is this if there if if that if
they're never presented with that choice
and that's what I would argue is that if
you walk down the street tomorrow in any
place they're going to say I didn't hear
about this I mean I would say this all
the time when I used to work at the RNC
and I'd call a reporter up and say hey
when I used to I get a call and take
little Tommy at you know Jefferson
Middle School did the filing bad with
what's the rnc's position right we get
called for everything and then some
prominent Democrat would do something
outrageous Arabic did you guys call the
DNC for comments every Washington Post
New York Times oh we didn't even know
that that occurred I'm like how did you
not know this Nancy Pelosi is the you
know minority leader speaker of the
house whatever positions yet well we
didn't hear about it so they'd never
report on these things so I guarantee
you the problem is that this is my point
that the that no one in the middle is
going to hear about this because the NBC
News is in the Washington Post aren't
going to report on it so the person in
the middle isn't going to even know that
it occurs except moderates do consume
some conservative media people a lot of
people watch this show that are in the
middle yeah well and that's again
there's I'm not saying that enough
people but the majority of Americans
when they wake up tomorrow morning and
watch you know Good Morning America The
Today Show or CBS it's not going to pop
up there whereas if it was a Glenn young
or a Ron DeSantis or Christy gnome
they'd see it you know you mentioned um
tolerance earlier and how the left and
the liberal mind used to be the tolerant
the side of Tolerance and then I because
I used to be like that I'm like accept
everybody everybody's cool whatever and
then you get these kind of these
behaviors of intolerance that come in
and you're like well I'll tolerate it
because I'm tolerance and then the
system starts to become intolerant I'm
like am I supposed to not tolerate
intolerance because then I'm the
intolerant one and and then what then
I'm the villain it's like that that
music video Tim that you did Will of the
people like am I supposed to say no this
villain is a villain and I do not
tolerate it then I become the villain
like at what point where's the balance
this is what your personal values are
right like you shouldn't tolerate things
that fly directly in your face I love
the idea of let everyone Live and Let
Live but in reality that's impossible to
do unless you have a common set of
values so you're coming to the adult
realization of conflict in where there
is no end point there is no position of
absolute moral Authority so you take a
look at what the left does they seem to
operate not on principle but on
Collective Vision if the zombie horde of
the left deems it so they do it even if
it's hypocritical to their previous
stance you see this with we talked about
the other day other day uh Brett brought
it up defiant elves where um that that
Dash guy posts you know this is why the
Republicans want to get rid of the FBI
and then a few months later he's like we
should completely get rid of the FBI
like there's no there's no logic other
than does it benefit me or not and so
the issue is one one thing that I've
talked about
people need to understand is
here's the question should parents have
final say in whether or not their
children receive a medical treatment
would you say yes or no 100 so then what
about the parents that want to give
their kids sex changes
should the government then intervene and
stop them from doing so I think below 18
uh yeah I mean if it's a life-altering
well change my point is simply this the
left argues parents should have a final
say in their child's development only if
it pertains to their ideological value
then when it comes to the uh you know
parents who are trying to stop the kids
from undergoing this to say the parents
are abusing the kids and the kids should
be protected by the state thus in
Washington children under age can go to
a doctor and get sex changes without
their parental consent right so the
issue is both sides are saying the same
thing but clearly one side is right well
I think their morality is based upon
collectivism and not principle our
morality is based on principle and not
collectivism and so my view is yeah
miners can't consent to these things
however the challenge then becomes we
actually do think there is a point where
the government should intervene and tell
a parent no you cannot give your child
this medical treatment but I mean think
about it if I mean so because if you
take that if one were to take that view
and a parent came in and said my
religion believes you need to have your
left arm cut off we'd say no you'd say
no because that's insane like so so and
again if you believe that below a
certain age that you are altering a body
to a to to do something that has well
this is my point your moral position
is not simply parents have final say a
lot of conservatives kept saying this
they kept saying parents should
determine what's right by kids so Rhonda
Santos was correct to pass the parental
rights and education Bill and then my
response was okay and if the parent
wants to give their child a sex change
no no no not then then the government
should intervene and it's like okay so
you do think there are instances where
the government should intervene based on
your morality now I agree with you I
think yes I think we are correct
children can't consent and they
shouldn't be getting these things but
the left in Washington has an inverted
worldview where they think children
should be able to go to a doctor without
their parents knowing and get these
treatments based on the same logic that
there that the government should
intervene if parents are abusing their
kids
so we thank a parent who wants to give a
kid a sex change is that's abuse and the
government should stop them for them in
Washington they think a parent who
blocks a kid from getting sex changed is
abusing that kid and the government
should be able to stop them they're both
arguing the same sentence with a
different it's like Scott Adams says
it's one screen but two different movies
being played to two different groups of
people that's why I'm like I I don't see
how you're going to be able to go to
those people and convince them but
anyway back to what you're saying Ian my
point is this that's why the statues
rotate and there's always a new villain
when for Frozen don't know the reference
we produced a music video several years
ago where these people are pulling down
a statue and it's a wheel a new Statue
comes up when one Statue gets pulled
down and then they pull the next one
down and another one comes up
there's a new Statue every time when
group a gets their leader put in Power
Group a doesn't revolt against him the
next Revolution is from Group B
Group B tears down the statue of command
of Captain a and then Group C protests
Group B
so if you get a Donald Trump in power
it's not like one day Trump supporters
go out in stage a revolution no the
Trump supporters are happy with Trump
it's the left that comes out in stages
the culture Revolution then when they
put Biden in it's the Trump supporters
that try to remove so that's why there's
always going to be the cycling this
wheel at cycling but as we develop a two
generations of Youth hyper polarized you
are you are setting the stage for an oh
outright Civil War you know I think
there is a potential outline silver
outline to this the very good outcome to
this is is that I I kind of agree with
you Sean about I think if it's a
life-altering surgery for a minor that
maybe there should be some oversight of
what a parent's going to do to a kid but
I don't think that it's up to us to stop
them from doing it I think it's the kids
that are getting changed that are
becoming adults and realizing what did
they do to me and now they're speaking
out that was like like Chloe Cole and
people that have been through this and
are like I will sue these companies and
maybe people will sue their parents I
don't know how it's going to come out
but I think that generation of people
are going to be the ones that speak up
and speak out to others that have are
going through it as 13 year olds or
nine-year-olds or whatever yeah I I'm
when we're talking about this I keep
thinking about this case from Canada
where uh uh I think she was like 14 year
old girl
um was a Jehovah's Witness and she was
diagnosed with lymphoma and she needed a
blood transfusion and that went against
the doctrines of her religion and she
was like I'm not gonna get it this is
what my family believes I don't want to
go through this and ultimately a court
in Canada intervened and ordered her to
go through the treatments
she would have died from lymphoma is
what they say without the treatment and
the treatment would have saved will have
saved her uh it's this very strange line
between did she have the right to refuse
it when she could have been saved are we
infringing on her religious rights she's
14 she's it's different than like a
six-year-old but she's still not an
adult at what point do we say there are
some things that we do to protect your
life so that you can become a full adult
and make the decisions on your own
exactly I'm living in a naturopathic
medicine that terrifies me that I would
think I know you have to take the
pharmaceutical under court order that's
ridiculous like you need you need diet
and exercise and sunlight those things
are like the basis of health so I don't
like that but it's not really a
naturopathic answer to the the gender
question right like that would be like
maybe go to therapy and talk about it
with someone and wait until you're older
to intervene but with transgender issues
there it has to be medical intervention
it has to be surgical it could be diet
too like stress if they're drinking a
lot of Pepsi when they're no offense
Pepsi if they're drinking a lot of sugar
when they're a little kid that could
tweak them out make them go crazy uh if
they're getting Adderall when they're
nine like that's the dietary also
believe yes you are born in the wrong
body and we need to intervene it's not
like they're going to be like so stop
drinking Pepsi and I don't care that you
know like there are some issues where uh
people's personal convictions conflate
against what actually might be the
safest route you know what I'm saying
yep yeah okay thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time